la agenda de campaña del presidente Joe
biden está repleta su antigua adversario
el ex presidente Donald Trump también
está muy ocupado durante esta temporada
de elecciones de mitad de mandato a sólo
cuatro días de que los estadounidenses
acudan a las urnas los dos rivales hacen
el último esfuerzo para influir en los
votantes el presidente byden visitó el
jueves Nuevo México y California en los
próximos tres días viajará Illinois Para
apoyar a la gobernadora y a los
congresistas demócratas en unas
elecciones muy disputadas antes de
visitar Pensilvania donde los demócratas
esperan conseguir un escaño clave en el
senado el presidente está dispuesto a
usar todas sus fichas en un mitin en
California el jueves hizo hincapié en la
importancia de estas elecciones
intermedias
cinco días cinco días para una de las
elecciones más importantes de nuestra
vida va a dar forma a nuestro país en
las próximas décadas el hecho es que
digo que esta es la lección más
importante
el presidente demócrata no ha dejado de
atacar a los republicanos durante su
gira electoral Donald Trump ha vuelto a
pasar al frente
el ex presidente también se ha sumado a
esta guerra de los mundos Trump sigue
teniendo un enorme peso en el partido
republicano y está dispuesto a impulsar
a sus candidatos en un mitilena Iowa
volvió a insinuar otra candidatura
presidencial en 2024
[Música]
este es el año en que vamos a recuperar
la cámara vamos a recuperar el senado
vamos a recuperar Estados Unidos y en
2024 lo más importante vamos a recuperar
nuestra magnífica Casa Blanca
las encuestas predicen que los
republicanos probablemente se harán con
la cámara de representantes el martes
mientras la carrera por el senado está
demasiado reñida para predecir
resultados